Well,
I mean,
just justice for me.
one of the reasons I love Shakespeare is
that justice,
you know,
I could say back to you at that level of
abstraction will justice is about
fundamental fairness.
Justice is about equality,
know among people who are similarly
situated,
justices about due process of law.
But I think precisely why I'm driven to
Shakespeare is because I don't think the
conversation really helps anybody at
that level of generality.
So we really need to think about
particular stories in particular case
studies in particular mythologies.
And one of the regrets that I have
about,
uh,
the otherwise wonderful nature of the,
of American diversity is that our
heterogeneity means that we have very
few common mythologies left to us.
So what I'm trying to do,
and Shakespeare is to try and say in the
same way that I would say to a law
school class about a case,
but I want to make this more available
to people who haven't gone to law school
and don't want to go to law school.
You know,
let's read the merchant,
read the merchant of Venice to me with
together with me against measure for
measure.
You know,
and the merchant of Venice is really
about a law that a society that takes
law too seriously,
like takes a letter of the law too
seriously,
which is to say,
Charlotte says,
I want my pound of flesh.
You know,
and the court of Venice is open to all
comers.
It's a cosmopolitan society.
It's a market society.
So it interprets that contract really
strictly.
And in fact,
this is in the play,
which is to say because this is a market
open to all comers,
people would lose faith in the law if we
didn't interpret all contracts really
strictly.
And so therefore sharla because entitled
to Antonio's pound of flesh and nobody
wants to live in that society,
right?
On the other hand,
it can't be that when portia says the
quality of mercy is not strained to drop
the pith of gentle rain from having upon
the place beneath and she has this great
encomium to mercy,
that mercy is what it's all about and
that all we need as an answer to this is
to be merciful to each other because
what real mercy would mean would really
be something that would strike at the
very heart of law.
And that's measure for measure.
The Duke at the beginning of measure for
measure,
just so people know,
since this is a less familiar play,
he's a duke of Vienna.
He has law,
the law fall into utter disrepair.
So he just hasn't enforced the law and
so lawlessness is sweeping the land.
Then my favorite line is the baby beats
a nurse like this is a world out of
joint.
You know,
hierarchy has been disrupted and so he
essentially leaves and leaves the
leaves,
a really strict a deputy and as place to
enforce the law,
but the deputy himself ends up violating
a law and then the dude comes in and
restores order.
But at the very end.
But Duke like issues all these pardons
to everybody who's broken the law all
over again.
So at the end of the play,
or we're no better off than we were at
the beginning.
So both the merchant and metric or
measure or describe worlds to us in
which neither of us would want to live
that no,
no one would want to live in.
Because you know,
the merchant of Venice doesn't have
enough mercy measure for measure has too
much marcy and no law.
So what is the answer to that?
I don't think that there's any easy
answer that says,
you know,
I'm going to titrate,
mercy and,
and the letter of the law if such a way
that we're going to have the perfect
balance and it's like,
ah,
you know,
two to one ratio of letter of the law to
mercy.
Like that's never going to be the case.
It's going to hatch that actually be on
the ground and with contacts.
But I think that looking at our common
mythologies,
it's going to help us understand that
and the reason that we have these
stories so that we understand that as
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes on sad and
you know,
the life of the law is not logic.
It's experience and it's experience of
these stories.
It's a fine grained every day,
you know,
muddy,
murky,
you know,
uh,
a nature of,
of life itself that we somehow have to
make sense of.
And the answer is not going to be,
well,
we should have the strict letter of the
law,
or we should have,
you know,
overflowing mercy.
Because neither of those is going to end
up in a society in which we want to
live.
But I'm trying to find that middle
space.
We're not going to be able to do that
through any kind of scientific formula.
It's not an algorithm.
It's not Algebra.
We're going to actually have to talk
about culture.
And that's what I'm trying to do.